YouTube the flash is back this is gonna
be my episode 16 video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
there was a whole bunch of zoom stuff
whole bunch of comic book Easter eggs so
here we go
we finally got a female speedster took
us two years but we finally got there
may she rest in peace love the way cisco
totally played that car like hey we
finally have a female speedster and then
they kill her in the same episode there
is a new round of the giveaway starting
in this video I'm also ending one so
I'll explain that at the end of all this
let's start with top 10 WTF I'll work on
Easter eggs as we go along anyone who is
a child of the 80s will probably
recognize this first one number 10 Barry
tries to jump the waterfall
this is totally Simpsons trying to jump
Springfield gorge
Homer thinks he's gonna make it he's
gonna make it he's gonna make it boom he
doesn't make it
I think Evel Knievel actually
guest-starred in that episode of The
Simpsons Cisco saved him from Homer
Simpson's faith and I guess we can argue
in the comments as to whether or not
Barry would have survived that fall
maybe like maybe but he probably would
have died number 9 WTF I'll put you in
an inescapable of daughter cube nice
Easter Egg for mother box talking about
new gods if you guys haven't read a lot
of New Gods it's old-school Jack Kirby
fourth world they're really weird
stories if you want to read something
current that they've been in you can
read Dark Side War Geoff Johns has been
writing that it's very New Gods heavy
number 8 WTF Jesse quicks band goes off
when she reaches to shake Wally West's
hand does that mean that Wally West is a
metahuman he's that going to have
something to do with him getting his
powers we don't know yet but I do think
it's a clue for Future Kid Flash is just
gonna be part of the explanation as to
how he gets Speed Force powers they
haven't really said anything about when
Wally's gonna get powers only that he
will be Kid Flash at some point they
they might not go with the kid flash
name
they might just use it to make fun of
him a little bit he's not that much
younger than Barry but number 7 WTF iris
west talks to Barry about them being
married on earth too and in the future
don't you think it's weird in the comics
the way they explain their children it's
really timing why me there's a lot of
time travel and fall because iris west
ends up secretly being from the future
so any explanation the show goes with if
they do show their children from the
future will be something way simpler way
easier to follow but they end up having
twins one of them is a girl she ends up
getting married to
viii on their child is bart allen but i
do think we're way too early for that
kind of stuff I like the way they're
using her editor now to balance that out
like they're teasing you with the idea
like hey isn't it weird that we're
married in the future should we think
about that yeah it's kind of a thing I'm
kind of preoccupied with zoom trying to
get faster now iris is preoccupied with
her editor who she has a lot of
chemistry with so if you're using the
Aero olicity stuff is a barometer for
relationships on the flash I I think
that they're way way behind
if Barry and iris ever do get together
I'm guessing it would be like late
season three
maybe season four they might push it off
indefinitely but eventually I do think
they'll get there but you have to keep
in mind that the flash will probably run
for like seven seasons so there's still
a long ways to go
number six WTF the flash versus
trajectory round one he gets his ass
handed to him I didn't like the way they
played with the reveal where they kept
using male pronouns and then they did
the reveal where it's a female speedster
we saw the promo months ago so we knew
it was gonna be a female speedster so
that twist didn't really play but you
have to keep in mind that a lot of
people will be watching this episode
without having watched that promo so it
is kind of funny the way they play it
and Cisco has that line where he's like
finally female speedster number five WTF
Caitlin goes to mercury labs she figures
out that her friend Eliza Harmon reverse
engineered a version of velocity nine
they don't really explain if it's the
exact same type of velocity nine or if
it's just a derivative it seems like
it's not quite as pure as the velocity
nine that Caitlin made and for whatever
reason Eliza is not able to manufacture
more so that's why she needs to get it
from STAR Labs but we get our first big
clue when it seems like she has a split
personality like the evil version of her
inside her mind speaking to her maybe
this is caused by the formula maybe this
always existed they're really vague
about the way they explained this
because we didn't know anything about
her before this but it stands to reason
that the version of the formula that she
took the one she reversed engineered
caused some of what's going on in her
mind right now and it's a big clue for
Jay Garrick and zoom number four WTF
trajectory takes down Jessie quick and
runs off with the velocity nine this is
more of a WTF for Jessie quick because
we know she'll probably eventually be a
speedster I'm really curious to see how
they explain it I don't think it's going
to happen right away
I think it's gonna be a while but I'm
hoping we see a lot more of Jesse quick
in future seasons fur for now she's just
kind of like floating off in the wind on
earth bun and in the comics she gets her
SuperSpeed by reciting a formula but
number three WTF Barry pulls off the
Homer Simpson goes Mach 3.3 which is way
way faster than he's ever been
takes down trajectory but is unable to
talk her down she injects herself with a
velocity nine in number two WTF her
lightning turns blue and her cells
degenerate as she goes faster and faster
until she turns into pure speed force
and that's the interpretation that I'm
choosing to take away from that that her
body didn't decay into nothingness which
is a clue for what might end up
happening to zoom eventually just
vanishing into the Speed Force in the
comics that's kind of what happened to
the very first version of the
reverse-flash his name was edward
clariss
he ended up running so fast he actually
had blue lightning he vanished into the
Speed Force but then later Rhema T
realized as pure energy and inhabited
the body of max mercury so there are a
couple things there borrowing from the
closet comics but I don't necessarily
think that's the exact explanation that
the TV show is gonna go with what's
gonna happen to zoom but I do like the
idea that you deal with the villain but
you provide a way for him to come back
in the future but finally my number one
WTF Cisco vibe zoom when he touches Jay
Garrick's helmet seemingly revealing
that Jay Garrick was zoomed the whole
time now right off the bat there are a
number of huge questions we have to ask
because I do like the simple way that
they're explaining it that zoom was
misleading them the whole time but then
again who is this body that looks like
Jay Garrick that zoom is dumping on the
ground the one that he killed and pulled
back through the wormhole is this
another version of Jay Garrick is this
an earth 2 version of every man or is
the conclusion the team flash came to
not the exact truth the way team flash
explains zoom killing Jay Garrick if
they're the same person his last season
when we saw Harrison wells talking to
the speed Mirage there's a couple
problems with that explanation though
that I'll explained I just feel like the
speed Mirage explanation doesn't hold up
because zoom wouldn't be able to pick a
speed Mirage up and carry it around it
wouldn't have a floppy head on this dead
looking body and he wouldn't be able to
dump it on the ground so this dead body
cannot be a speed Mirage there has to be
some other explanation
if you believe the simple explanation
that these are both the same person and
there's just some speed force trickery
at play then who is the person in the
iron mask because that seems like the
real earth one Jay Garrick the other
explanation it's a little less likely
but it's totally possible that just the
way it was visualized all this zooms
stuff all these clues just didn't work
out exactly the way the writers wanted
them to like conceptually I like the
idea like what if Jay Garrick were zoom
what if we made it look like he killed
himself that's a great idea but if he
wanted that to be the case then you
wouldn't have shown this scene with him
dumping a separate Jay Garrick body on
the ground there would be no second Jay
Garrick it would have just been zoom
walking in and pulling the mask off so
let me know in the comments what do you
think the explanation is for zoom Jay
Garrick in this other Jay Garrick body
right here really I still feel like it's
earth one Jay Garrick in that iron mask
but let me know what you guys think
there's still so many things the show
has to explain when the season is done
we can give them a report card for the
way they weaved all these mysteries
together because I love the concept and
I feel like it's gonna be really hard
for them to stick the landing stray
observations
who knew earth - Harrison wells was such
a Kanye West fan and even though it
sucks they killed their female speedster
Eliza Harmon ends up dying in the comics
anyway the way she dies is that because
she got her powers through Lex Luthor's
everyman project he has the ability to
turn them off at will so he turns off
her speed and she dies in a battle so
she wasn't really long for this world
anyway hopefully we'll get our next
female speedster in season 3 if not
before then major bonus points - their
costume designer for making her costume
look like earth 3 Johnny quick from the
comic books
he's the flash of the crime syndicate
giveaway time though congratulations to
last week's giveaway the the old
giveaway has started
Anthony Sanchez you went to IMAX gift
certificates to Batman vs Superman you
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details that's just on the about
page there is a new round of the
giveaway that's starting right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video don't forget there's a new episode
of arrow tomorrow night there is no
legends of tomorrow so my next DC video
after that will probably be my
non-spoilery Batman V Superman review
that won't post til
Thursday night the hype is real there
are so many awesome things happening
right now I'm really hoping that the
flash this season doesn't turn into lost
with the way they kind of lose
themselves in the explanation but why
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here to learn all about
the flash and Supergirl crossover and
you can click here for my Game of
Thrones Season 6 behind-the-scenes video
all kinds of White Walkers thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight